calcul mental est signé par fo doc
gynéco
bah oui oh merde ah bon touati fort en
calcul mental
cette route est c'est cette bouteille
alors attention
28 - 16 12
ouais pas mal neuf fois 763 5 x 5 x 5
103 5 x 5 x 5 5 x 50 125 est très bon il
est passé personnes ont passé les deux
mois la racine carrée de 64 à la base il
a raté une carte de 68
nab a ma gueule il fait beau il est beau
temps dès la racine carrée 221,12
[Rires]
louyest et 123 plus 450 623 puisse 450
623 plus 450 623 vincent tu dis bravo
bien cinq cents soit 6 cents à 3 979 à
quoi est ce plus avoir alors la tâche
d'en faire une là si tu sais tu trouves
ça l'a déjà je suis étonnée je t'ai dit
la racine carrée de neudorf n'était pas
à l'antenne racine carrée de 9 puisqu'un
racine carrée de 36,9 c'est un chiffe
invariable ça reste toujours neuf non la
quinzaine caritatif et non pas du tout
attention aux variables et n'a droit +6
égale neuf semaines à mal c'est vrai
c'est toujours neuf ça fera toujours si
racine carrée le note plus racine carrée
de contis a fait 9
oui d'accord mais pas les notes
non
[Applaudissements]
geithner d'efforts c'est bizarre dans la
boîte était nul qu'est ce qui a bien pu
se passer
les noms
une oreillette non mais je savais alors
maintenant je suis ton posé une sans
oreillettes pétrissant pose une sans
oreillettes allez tiens voilà cette puce
est no 14
pas mal treize fois 6 allez on se revoit
de 96
mais non non 78 merci et bas sans
oreillettes c'est plus toutes les faits